[Música]
y
por primera vez en sus 75 años de
historia la asamblea general de las
naciones unidas se está celebrando de
manera virtual y los discursos de los
mandatarios mundiales que estamos
escuchando han sido pre grabados por
supuesto el tema común a todos ellos es
la pandemia y sus consecuencias sociales
económicas y sanitarias multilateralismo
está siendo el término más escuchado
hasta ahora todos los países apuestan
por una respuesta conjunta ante esta
pandemia y eso que eeuu anunció hace dos
meses su salida de la organización
mundial de la salud
donald trump en su discurso de
inauguración ha vuelto a atacar a china
culpando la de infectar al mundo con
este nuevo virus y en esta asamblea
general algo que hemos visto positivo es
que por primera vez todos los líderes
latinoamericanos han llegado con un
objetivo común y es acabar con la cob y
[Música]
en la onu el presidente bolsonaro dijo
que brasil está siendo víctima de una
campaña de desinformación sobre los
incendios que te bajan el pantanal que
es el humedal más grande del mundo y la
amazonía brasileña y culpó sin pruebas a
organizaciones internacionales que tildó
de antipatrióticas además dio la
responsabilidad de los incendios a los
indígenas que según él estarían quemando
los pastos para poder cultivar cuando en
realidad todos los expertos de brasil y
los expertos internacionales dicen que
las áreas habitadas por indígenas hay
menos incendios y relacionan los juegos
con la actividad delictiva de los
materiales ilegales y de los ganaderos
además sin prueba alguna
bolsonaro culpo a venezuela del derrame
de petróleo que a principio del año
manchó las costas de la parte noroeste
de brasil por esta razón muchas
organizaciones nacionales
internacionales han tildado
a bolsonaro de mentiroso incluso la
asociación brasileñas de la prensa ha
dicho que él personaron metió en varias
ocasiones y que cubrió brasil de
vergüenza
[Música]
ante el pleno de las naciones unidas- de
manuel misma con reiteró la necesidad de
un nuevo orden mundial más en medio de
esta pandemia y explicó cuáles serían
las bases sobre las cuales reposaría por
una parte la lucha contra la
proliferación de las armas de
destrucción masiva y la lucha contra el
terrorismo tanto en medio oriente como
en áfrica además un nuevo paradigma de
la estabilidad de europa que el
continente europeo y su seguridad no
estén en manos de terceros ni dependan
de pactos firmados históricamente entre
eeuu y rusia
hablo de bienes comunes es decir un
mejor sistema de salud la lucha contra
el calentamiento global y una regulación
también del internet en cuarto lugar
hablo de la educación en especial de las
niñas en el continente africano y por
último la defensa de los derechos
humanos y la lucha contra la desigualdad
el mandatario francés espera que este
nuevo orden mundial quede firmado y
acordado durante el foro por la paz que
tendrá lugar aquí en parís en el mes de
noviembre
[Música]